this my lad from the lot Salam alaikum
peace be with you and I may be your host
and we're gonna be right back
when we reaching out to the people of
the Balkan area and people from all
around the globe and we're gonna be
addressing some of the misconceptions
about this beautiful way of life and
we're going to be trying to soften the
hearts of people who've been away from
the crater and they've been following
their lusts and desires so nature nigde
such a Maserati please excuse me for my
broken Bosnian but I'll be back to give
you some more broken Bosnian Shalala I
hear on the Dean show with imam spent
dean here on the dean show peace
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam to LA now
can you go ahead and we know in English
that what we just said is peace be with
you how do you express that in the
Albanian language what we just said I'll
be honest with you my opinion is that
weak such that if I were to try to
translate probably be wrong but I think
it's something to the extent of patra
choice committee I think in Bosnia it's
Nikki Emir too stubborn please correct
us you know we look for someone to do
some for these shows that we've done if
they can go ahead and put the subtitles
in in the Bosnian language and hopefully
we can you know use this session also to
practice on your obey Nia in my Bosnian
you were born in New Jersey or no you
came home Macedonia and you came over
from from the at the age of one about
one years old yeah I was born in New
York family is from Bosnia and I still
speak a little bit of it but hopefully
you know we can capture some people's
attention by speaking the language so
they can say hey what's all this about
and maybe insha'Allah we can solve with
some hearts and bring them back to Allah
to the Creator that's what we're here
for that's what we're here for
so let's continue on you have your own
section of the deen show.com people can
go there the deen show al hamdulillah is
viewed internationally all around the
globe so for those people that are
watching us on the TV they can go to the
deen show calm to see your previous
episode episode now we love the best for
all of mankind our roots stems from
Europe and particularly the Balkan area
but it seems like the people from this
area they've kind of drifted off to
follow other cultures and they're not
really following Islam so we mentioned
some of the superstitions we mentioned
in the last show people watching because
people you know
when they're watching someone and that
someone is an imam for instance right
and he's smoking let's say he's using
profanity or he's doing some things that
are opposite to Islam
now that reflects bad on the religion
the way of life so let's give some
advice to the people out there who have
kind of fallen into these traps and
they've gone away from Islam because
they've seen their local Imam from the
Albanian or Bosnia community you know
doing some things that just the fitrah
the inside of human being just rebels
but now they because of a human being
they were rebelled totally away from the
way of life from the crater have you
seen these things to an Albanian culture
yeah I have and I'm sure perhaps you've
also heard this same statement where in
Albanian they would say hold your
thought and buncee three of the most
buncee boy do as i say but don't do as I
do it's exactly yeah do it do as I say
not as I do right which unfortunately
when it comes to that type of a man that
type of a Hodja
if this is what he's doing that he is
living opposite to what he is himself
speaking meaning that there's a
hypocrisy that's there it turns people
away and this is something that our
people I think have that they have
experienced you know what I mean I
remember hearing something from some of
the elders who've grown up in the Balkan
area where they've mentioned things that
with regards to the Hodges that are
there or the sheiks and the Imams that
have actually been reasons to turn them
away from Islam things that I have no
idea how true they are or what the
reasons behind them are but if we think
about it especially now it's stuff that
doesn't make sense
for example they would say that the
Hodja would tell them if you ride a
bicycle that you will become a kafir do
not ride a bicycle
this isn't they do this in Albania this
is what they were saying back in Albania
and Macedonia in these areas but it was
funny because they would then say that
they'd see the same Hodja riding the
bicycle and say Hodja what's going on
man you're the one who's telling us
don't ride a bicycle because if you do
this this and there you go riding it and
what would be the answer
do as I say don't do as I do but you can
ride a bike this says where did he come
up with this you can ride a bike you can
write a plane does a trained donkey a
horse I can totally say something like
this
Allahu Alem ya Elohim it's interesting
you know the other thing is you'll find
that the Hodja himself you know they'll
they'll be doing things that what we
hear and see today of for example maybe
smoking hanging out in bars
you know cafes things of that sort where
perhaps they're not the most righteous
of acts or the most righteous of
locations and they'll say well if Y is
the hoja doing these things you see and
this has got to tell you something about
the religion and so on and so forth look
for us to understand that huija myself
or anybody we are not the standard by
which Islam is to be judged
it's the prophet muhammad sallallahu
anywa said them he was the best example
for us keresh often Pagar Baden Muhammad
in le salatu salam a show of him to see
arden at the opponent usnea luca condors
to muna children he soul alone is some
never contradicted anything of his
speech with his actions or his actions
with his speech he was the best example
and this is what we need to pay
attention to no muslim regardless male
or female no matter where you're from a
Muslim who has submitted himself to the
one who created him he shouldn't be
indulging in in illicit sexual
activities promiscuity alcohol gambling
that's an average layman okay there's no
gambling you can't have been you could
have been the worst of these but you
repent and you you know come back to the
crater and he forgives all sins right if
you're sincere but now you're an imam
you're a spiritual leader you should I
mean now you're gonna have double
punishment from the Creator because
people are looking up to you you're an
example for for the community is this
right
absolutely the difference between a
layperson and someone who was considered
an imam a [ __ ] joshi a scholar Mufti
whatever the different terms maybe
they're not one in the same
and so anybody can come from a
background that is not a righteous one
but once they make that step they make
that decision and take that step to
repent to be the servant of Allah that
they know they should be the Muslim that
they know they should be that's it it
should be finalized with regards to
anything of Haram in their lives
especially in the sense of somebody who
was going to be looked at as a religious
leader somebody who's going to be looked
at as an example in a role model you
know and our people are interesting they
have a lot of the maserati's know just
stories
yeah I'm sure you've heard about them
too or in the Arabic no sort of demon of
joy and there's a lot of wisdom in them
so they themselves will tell you stories
about what religious elements they are
of the time that the hoja is walking
down the street and there's the drunk
man on the corner he goes to me you fear
Allah how do you don't look at you
you're ruining your life and your family
and everything else and so he looks up
to him and he says hey you're right he
goes but for me if I mess up it's only
myself that I'm really harming but you
when you mess up and do these things
you're harming many a people they know
these things they know these things and
this is why our Hajus they should fear
Allah our Hodges they really are Imams
they really need to understand that they
are role models and whatever they do a
bad especially that it's public or
especially even worse than that if
they're teaching that it's permissible
these are things that are in no way a
light matter and they may very well be
reasons for them being punished by Allah
I assuage ed for leading people astray
yeah three series on the day of judgment
they're gonna have some serious
accountability absolutely absolutely so
that's why we're doing this episode so
we can soften the hearts and we can make
sure we're doing the right thing and not
the wrong thing to please our created
before we meet our Creator we'll be
right back with more here on the Deen
show do you think these things are gonna
bring you happiness
you know what you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction
it's going to end up causing you if it
hasn't already a lot of pain you're
happy really what we are offering in
Islam what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
aren't pleased they're at rest they're
not discontent we are pleased with what
we have
Forrester's sanam - leo de nadine show
ya some Eddie over a marsh man team
finished at the prestigious
Modena University you graduated there is
this correct
you speak the arabic language fluently
you've been your the imam at the local
center in rockford correct yeah and
you're also albanian and we are trying
to reach out to the Albanian said of
Bosnia instead of people from the Balkan
area but everybody can benefit because
I'm sure many people who start to follow
the Sunnah the way of the last and final
messenger you get you start to get
resistance in every community and every
ethnicity so we want everyone to really
appreciate what we got because it's from
the crater that happens in earth so tell
us we also see some of these things that
are prevalent much of the religion has
been taken as a business so you'll see
people who now because when you don't
have a law in your life there's a void
you're not living your purpose there's a
void in your heart so people feel that
I've experienced this myself and I've
seen many people in my family who have
gone to certain magicians that they have
so these people even Imams they'll come
to them and they'll say look I feel sick
I don't feel good they don't question
them about the prayer because that is a
formula to relieve your sickness right
they're praying to the crater
establishing the correction with him so
they give them the easy way they take
their money and then they give them
what's called Hamal ear something that
they wear around their neck and now we
mentioned this in the last show can you
expound on it does this have anything to
do with Islam and the eye Miley is as we
would also say Alma Leah yeah you know
it's not just about us here in America
and this fast food society and
fast-paced society that we're living in
where we want fast results like this
without really having to do anything we
will go to people will go to these Imams
and that's how they're known as being
Hajus immense to find help for problems
that you know Allahu Alem whether it's
man-made or otherwise they'll go
they'll be asked most of the time for
something of information articles of
personal belongings things of this sort
and sometimes they'll even say come back
after a period of time and then when the
person comes that they'll have some
further information to convince the
person that told this person knows what
the heck he's talking about and they'll
then write for them this talisman where
they'll basically put in all sorts of
different things and I've had the
opportunity to open some of them up
where you see strange configurations of
shapes and numbers and letters and
repetition and stuff that doesn't make
sense and who knows what it is with
sometimes things of Kuran and then they
fold it up and they give it to the
person and say okay now just as long as
you make sure you keep this attached to
the baby you put this under your pillow
you do this or that it's going to make
everything better this is magic it can
be magic especially if it's not somebody
who's just playing games looking to make
money in there you know some hooligan
benefiting from the ignorance of people
if it's somebody who really knows what
they're doing it's magic they're dealing
with ginyan we've heard stories about
this stuff where the person even before
they walk into the to see the person
that the the Imam is telling them you're
so-and-so when your family is so and so
on you're here to talk to me about this
issue and the people just like wow this
guy is really the real deal and stuff
and so on and so forth
that's magic to deal with magic whether
you're an imam or not an email these are
things that the believer should be as
far away from as possible instead of us
realizing that Allah he is an a fear
Allah is the one that brings all all
height all goodness all benefit in
seeking help with Allah we right away go
to find these types of individuals and
have them do all sorts of crazy hopeless
pocus magic and things that have soared
on is hoping that they're gonna make
things better and it doesn't you know it
might but what it might do is and people
don't recognize this that magic can mask
things but there's a price to it so
somebody who's sitting there thinking
gold you know my you know my daughter is
not feeling well and it's
seems like there's something of a
problem and now you're actually now
introducing gin into her life that are
going to be further messin with her
you're actually now doing things that
are who knows what what you have agreed
to with regards to this hoja with
regards to this email I mean these are
things that a person does not want to
play with so you don't heal this way you
heal by the Quran reading the Quran that
would be the curse would be Rukia look
yeah
none of this magic stuff magic no Imam
no matter how big his beard is or short
his beard is or big his hat it
he shouldn't be touching a woman that's
not his wife and you see a lot of this
going on he shouldn't be touching her at
all I'll be honest with you on this
point of the physical touch it seems
like there may be some difference of
opinion I'm not absolutely convinced of
one decision or the other on it in the
same way that if perhaps and the analogy
is made that there would be physical
contact in the same way that a doctor
who is looking to diagnose and help a
you know a patient that's of the
opposite gender but definitely it can be
done without touching the person that's
something that there should be no no
difference of opinion on but that I mean
either way you know going in the room
and by themselves and you know we've
heard crazy stories going on fondling
all these other crazy especially never
alone right and these are some of the
things that have been heard nothing to
do with Islam okay so we need to get to
know Islam we need to be people is it
right that we read the Quran and then we
go to people of knowledge but you know
sometimes people been let down by some
of these people who they hustle them so
what do they do then what do they do
they should look to see that the
hamdulillah today the Quran has been
translated in Bosnian several
translations translated now Danian
several translations hamdulillah after
the war in Bosnia the war in Kosova so
much literature is now available in the
original language so that people who not
like myself for English is my stronger
language maybe like my parents or
whatever the case is they can go and
look to find information that is
authentic and hamdulillah in the native
language so that they can learn
so that there's no excuse for ignorant
these days you know one of the typical
arguments in the past was but no quiche
in pork
we weren't Turks we didn't understand we
didn't know they prevented us or
whatever the case is well if that was
the case back then that's definitely not
the case today there's no excuse for
ignited a let's give the people the
basic formula that the creator sent down
through all the messages of God God is
one and we only worship Him so some of
the basic things that you know they
could start doing today they've lived a
life of transgression of sin you know
they've been doing things that is not
pleasing to the Creator and now you know
what they're watching the show and they
want to submit to God what's the first
thing they should do first thing is
remove all middlemen there should be no
agencies no intermediaries no people no
Saints no angels no prophets no nothing
that a person beats places between them
and Allah so if there's going to be
anything of communication that should
come from the heart let it be directly
from your heart to Allah who is oej
supplicate asking Allah who so vahana to
help you ask Allah to forgive you ask
Allah to guide you ask a lot to heal you
and if you can use the beautiful names
of Allah the healer the guide in the
process of the doís it makes it all the
stronger so that if you're sick
and you want help to be healed you would
say oh Allah the healer healed me oh
Allah the guide please guide me guide my
children and so on and so forth knock
those middle people out Nikko's Rodino
some Allah no one in the middle just
Allah which Allah who not soldier a
chart may you not be at it man demon
demon a deed which may you file you'll
ask the nice in theatre as female age
verse beeping our Belvoir SP and Santa
as Joe he fortunate the clan Yosh start
to pray the prayer is absolutely
essential this is not something you do
when you're forty fifty and you've had
you know all your good times now you
saying oh I'll do Hajj when I'm 50 you
need to do these actions before you die
which can be right after the show
absolutely nobody has any guarantee of
how long they're going to live the
prayer is so important if we understand
that most of our people know this from
like the eel Mahal and from you know the
the other things of what they read that
the Prophet but it's not
some was given the five daily prayers
during the Mirage when he was up in
Jenna we know how important the prayers
are so absolutely start making those
five daily prayers even if you cannot
make all of them start with one of them
and be consistent in it see how good it
feels to surrender to submit to put your
head to the ground to realize how much
you need a lot and how great Allah is
and when you're there in such that after
you've said super hard that I'll be an
Islander three times my lord the most
high is perfect let your heart pour out
to him ask him for whatever it is that
you're going through the help that you
need the strengths that you're looking
for Allah can make it all happen
Allah has the only one that can make it
happen and you're going to be missing
out if you're not doing this because at
the end you're gonna die and then when
you die you wish you would have made
that prostration but at the end it's too
late it's too late and even if you are
brought to the message it to the Jama
and the hoja washes you when you get
everything done of an Islamic burial
that's probably not gonna mean anything
if you have not even once put your head
to the ground or once asked a lot to
forgive you and this is something that
needs to be paid attention to
we're gonna be right back with more
inshallah aquabug da to wrap up this
show we'll be right back
okay you've got your dream home and
you've got your dream car but you're
gonna get old and things are gonna
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are gonna die and we're gonna meet
our Lord and He is going to judge us it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person and
bad for the society
back here on the D show with Imam Sheikh
and Dean born in Albania raised in New
Jersey and finished at the Medina
University so you're in rockford
presently yep yeah tell us you you deal
with a lot is there a big Albanian
Bosnian community in that area there is
we have a very large Bosnian especially
but also Albanian community yeah what is
it what are some of the dilemmas that
you've seen the obstacles that hinder
people from living their purpose the
purpose that was revealed through the
crater to heaven earth to us to mankind
through his last and final messenger
probe Mohammed what are some of the
problems that you see that particularly
the albanian Bosnian Muslims are facing
well there is that the disconnect with
regards to the Masjid that disconnect
with regards to being the the Muslims
that the law has really wants us all to
be happy nah many of them they have very
strong work ethics and they think that
that hamdulillah by being very good
workers and providers that almost as if
that suffices everything else the other
issue that I also find is and those are
good things but they don't suffice I
mean there has to be a balance in life
one of the other things I still notice
is that the adults of them their English
is still very weak so the first
generation of our people their English
is very weak the second generation it's
the opposite that the English is strong
in the native tongue is very weak and so
there is a communication a communication
gap that's there between the two
generations as well as with regards to
for example our Masjid and I don't know
about others but in our mission
everything is for the most part in
English and so some of those who are
older whose English may not be good they
may feel that perhaps there's they're
not able to connect but alhamdulillah I
know that many of us we can understand
another language far better than were
able to speak in it you know what I mean
yeah for the / almost out of time so I
just have a few more points I want I
want to throw it the person says you
know what as far as the prairies Muslim
she's Muslim he says look I got to work
a coach at Mohammad Rafi I got to work
oh yeah volume Allah who sits it I love
a law in my heart
that's sufficient for me we gotta say
about this we do have to work at
hamdulillah and we should love Allah in
our heart the love in our heart though
has to be more than just words it has to
be shown in action in the same way that
if we were to go tell our employer look
man I love you when I you know and and
and I'm an employee here but if you
don't clock in and you don't put any
time into the actual job they're gonna
fire you nobody's gonna pay you in the
same way that if we were to understand
look Allah
jeanna Allah Ginetta and paradise that
is created it's not free that there has
to be action from your part from the
heart out out through the body to show
that you are serious that you are
genuine so if we're going to say we love
Allah it has to be proved by the way we
live our lives as Muslims they can talk
is cheap but it's too many times before
you can say I love you but if you don't
back it up with actions it doesn't mean
nothing it means nothing
does it matter doesn't matter if you're
you know you yeah I mentioned this in
the first episode that you mentioned his
prayer you know praying to the Creator
alone not his creation you mentioned
going to Hajj doing the five basic
pillars and now the person say well my
great-great-grandfather he did Hajj 10
times is that gonna help you out at all
over the day judgment that's gonna help
the grandfather out but not the person
themselves each person is going to
benefit from what they have done no
one's gonna be able to give no one's
gonna even want to give what they have
done of good to the other person on the
day of judgment you've got time now son
you've got time you're young you're 20
you know have some fun you can be become
you know more religious you can turn to
you know Allah when you get my age the
parents are saying is they're saying
this and they themselves are seeing how
many our mouths are dying from
automobile accidents drinking and
driving drugs sudden death and who knows
of other things these same parents
should wake up and they need to wake up
and realize look this is not the way
that you're going to have your children
there for you as you get older that
you're not going to see grandkids from
this fast dangerous lifestyle that
you're promoting in your children last
closing comments are just to reach out
to the people who speak this language
Albanian what advice do you have for
the advice that I have is this look I
myself haven't grown up in Jersey I
didn't have access to communication
about Islam and when I did go to the
Albanian mission that we had it was more
of a social club than anything I think
that with regards especially the young
adults that we have today of Albanian
and Bosnian etc you have so much
available to you so much access even if
it is in English that can help you that
can be there for you in a way that it
wasn't there for us 20 years ago when we
were first looking so take advantage of
what's available
venya Mandan and hamdulillah Kenan the
Jewish epoch in Indian Bosnia keenya
Libra karana chachi proximal some center
simondon ep Athena Mia coupe tobu Korean
Islamic and that the zoo and Yvette tini
Robert allahu subhanahu wa'ta'ala seized
would fall upon Allah Allah not reduced
us abuse namah Allah reward you for
being with us finally maintain Eva Shoen
block for a lot of publicity thank you
well even salam wa tuula and follows the
stability number nadine show thank you
very much for tuning in and I can
promise you one thing that we will all
die it doesn't matter if you're Serbian
Croatian Bosnian or any one of these
nationalities but if you die in a state
of submission to the one who created you
you will be successful not only in this
life but definitely in the next and we
want to stay away from the Hellfire and
an easy way to get there is by following
your lusts and desires your way we don't
want to do it our way we want to do it
the crater's way so ask him for guidance
and he will facilitate away only praying
to the one God you know that there's a
void in your heart there's something
missing and that cannot be filled with
money drugs women men none of these
material things you have to you have to
submit what are separated ot on I should
territorial and that's a law that's the
one creator God Almighty pray to Him
beseech his help beg for his forgiveness
he will help you in this life in the
next we'll see you next time don't
forget to pick up the new dean show DVD
volume 4 also we have dunya to dean is
it's finally out alhamdulillah
ah you can go to Eddie DVD com pick
these up use them as a tool for the dawa
and share the purpose of life we got the
bumper stickers the t-shirts get out
there do the doll invite people to
purpose to the purpose of life and get
the reward get the reward we'll see you
next time insha'Allah God willing peace
be unto you